ten
nine
eight
seven
six
five four
three
two
one ghost writer be on the page
howdy
we are back and ready for the next
episode of ghost writer beyond the page
today we're going to dig in deeper with
one of my personal favorite books
because we're going to jump into the
wild wild west
of outer space with trinity
written by
yours truly
that's me right there i really loved
writing this book because it's full of
adventure and excitement and twists and
turns as the two main characters hitch
and dale travel along a winding trail in
search of the truth
so i'm really excited to see
what winding road ghost rider is going
to put dawn on to get her closer to
finishing her story let's check it out
welcome to donna's video diary
so far we have who sapphire the spider
and now we have where for my setting i
decided what better place for sapphire
and her friends than a place we all know
is filled with amazing adventures
surprises and information the bookstore
i think writing about a place i can
really picture
is gonna help me feel more sure of my
descriptions plus it's so cool to think
about the bookstore from sapphire's tiny
perspective the fashion section is where
she of course spends most of her time
but she also goes to school in the
textbook section with her friends
and her older brother spelman plays
soccer in the sports section there's so
many amazing places they can explore
right there in the store now
let's see what might be up next
nothing
i thought ghost writer would have shared
something by now
why
ghostwriter is really sticking to a
pattern with these hints let's see
why
hmm
why why why
well hello there miss donna
what is it you're trying to solve dale
i'm so glad you're here
you always show up to save the day well
i'm flattered is there something you
need help with some kind of mission
you could say that
i really want to finish this uh mission
but
i keep getting stuck that is tricky for
me when it comes to fighting crime and
chasing down scoundrels it's certainly
much harder to come up with resolution
if you don't know what the real problem
is
when hitch and i were after the camera
real kid we didn't know what he was
after or where he was headed but
once we figured out he was after the
trinity we had a much better chance of
catching him as we were trying to
recover the trinity we ran into
conflicts and obstacles every step of
the way from an army of knights and
armor to a double cross in mayor
wow what a story it's like every moment
builds on top of the one before
until everything finally gets fixed
wait
dil that's perfect you have no idea how
much you just helped you totally saved
my day very glad to hear it
i'll be on my way hitch is waiting at
the station for me
best of luck miss donna
what dare goes through in trinity
all of the ups and downs the action
moments and the resolution she finally
comes to with hitch
those are all elements you need to
create a plot of any story
i've so got it this hint is all about
plot it's the whole reason why i've put
together my character and setting to
actually put them into the story i bet
there's a good chapter in trinity full
of action-packed plot moments to help me
out
let's try chapter eight
at this point in the story we already
know that the ribbons are a rebel colony
living on a planet called tensor4 and
they're causing a lot more trouble than
anyone realized i can't wait to read how
dale uses her training as a sky marshal
to help her out
come out come out the bald riven call to
dale in a sing-song voice
you don't want us to blow up in the
hatch now do you
whoa
dale's mind raced she was scared
really scared
what do you want from me she called out
from you nothing at all the riven called
back you're free to go
we want your ship
no they couldn't get the ship
it would be better if it was destroyed
and dale knew how
okay dale called i'm coming out
she had to work fast if the riven
suspected that something wasn't right
they might blow up the ship
just getting my gear together dale
yelled
all deputies were taught to be prepared
for situations like this one
it was a drastic move but dale saw no
other way
she stood over the cockpit controls and
entered a series of special commands her
fingers flew over the control console
inputting the commands and what she'd
hoped was the exact right order because
she wouldn't be getting a second chance
there were 20 commands in all
when she reached the final one she held
her breath and threw the last toggle
switch
instantly every light on the cockpit
panel flashed red
yes dale pumped her fist in victory she
done it
the ship was disabled forever
no command can make it ever fly again
from that moment on the ship was about
as useful as a garbage dumpster
time's up the riven was losing his
patience
okay i'm coming out dale ran to the far
side of the ship where her flight cycle
lubell sat
she jumped into the saddle and powered
up
lulu bell rose a few inches off the deck
dale punched a command into her
wristband computer and the ship's hatch
door began to rise
she got lulubel's engine and sped
forward she flew through the opening
with barely an inch overhead to spare
dale shot away from the ship past the
group of surprised rivens and into the
night
that was amazing
this chapter is basically a whole story
by itself
as dale overcomes the trouble with the
ribbons it all makes so much sense now
a story is made up of the setup or
exposition
the conflict with all of its obstacles
and finally the resolution
let's dive right in
donna is in great shape she's been
working really hard and she has come up
with her characters
she's come up with her setting
and now she's working out all the
interesting key plot points for her
story and i hope you are too you're
still working on your story right and
you're still writing those ideas down in
your bullet journal because there's no
better way to brainstorm ideas than
writing it down in your journal so i
hope you're doing that
and if you want to dive deeper into the
ghostwriter world be sure to pick up
trinity and read it it's my book
and then go to the wild wild ghost
section of the activity guide and as
always check in with the entire ghost
writer gang on apple tv plus for
episodes of the show so until then
we'll see you